imagine because of this some [ __ ]
creep is like I think I have the power
to taste yeast infections
the Marvel intro
[Music]
so this was a very very interesting
story and I'm very happy to share here
today uh anybody here familiar with
Parkinson's disease yeah dude that's
what took my homie Michael J fox
he's dead no actually he's still alive
sorry
but that's what made him took his career
yeah shaky and stuff on the streets
they're known as the Harlem shakers oh
wow really wow yeah that's what I heard
in hip-hop Omarion told me
Maria so uh for anybody who is not
familiar with the Harlem uh disease
whatever
Parkinson's disease is a progressive
disorder that affects the nervous system
and the parts of the body controlled by
the nerves and there is a woman out
there who can smell it
shut up she like a dolphin that knows
when you're pregnant she can [ __ ]
what that's a thing that's a thing
that's the thing yep that's crazy like
dolphins know when women are pregnant
people have dolphin birds like people
will go women there's some women that
really believe in it they will go and
they will be put in like a pool with
dolphins and the Dolphins will help them
birth their babies wow how will they
help them birth are they like pushed
it's like a whole thing that dolphins
are super super connected to like
children and they [ __ ] do the sonar
[ __ ] like then they [ __ ] just bite
the umbilical cord Aquaman yeah
wow okay well yeah there's there's this
way lady out there who can smell
Parkinson's disease and the crazy part
about it is that now scientists have
developed the first ever skin swap test
that can diagnose Parkinson's disease in
only three minutes thanks to this woman
and her great sense it's actually like a
molecular clue yeah the deficiency is
she the only one that can be the test
though because if she dies no one could
never she's helped develop the test so
now the test can be done by anybody
because I thought she was there sniffing
all day like oh Parkinson no Parkinson
Parkinson's no Parkinson has been for
quite some time so basically over 40
years ago
foreign
so over 40 years ago Joy Milne of Perth
Scotland was about 10 years into
marriage when she noticed her husband
Les started to smell a little off
specifically around his shoulders and
neck while Joy knew she had a strong
nose for scent having been diagnosed
with hereditary hyper rosmia hyperosmia
oh good she couldn't get over the abrupt
change in his odor I mean most lives
just be like
go take a [ __ ] shower you'd think you
smell like a [ __ ] well so that's that's
basically what it was at first you know
figuring it was unpleasant like this
musty type of odor she began accusing
the then 33 year old Les of poor hygiene
and he Oh I thought you could say
cheating too yeah yeah it's like typical
no no poor hygiene poor hygiene
obviously he was upset by this over time
uh Joy would drop the subject but 12
years later the smell was still going
strong and she began to notice less mood
shifting when the couple went to the
doctor he was diagnosed with Parkinson's
okay after years of grappling with the
degenerative disorder of on their own
joy and less decided to join a support
group for patients and their families
upon entering the room for the first
time Joe was shocked to smell the same
must he scent on all the other
Parkinson's patients wow oh that's
amazing it still would be so [ __ ]
funny if she was like are you cheating
on me with a woman who has Parkinson's
he's like damn whoever this girl is she
stinks what does she have over me yeah
Parkinson's
[Laughter]
so uh before Les's 2015 passing
the former doctor connected Joy with a
professor at the University of Edinburgh
to see how her Sensational gift
Sensational is very good did you make
that pun or was that in the article an
articles
I take credit when I think I did could
be used within the medical community as
a test they had her blind sniff the
t-shirts of a mix of individuals with
and without Parkinson's and she got only
one wrong during this test or so they
thought because the shirts she
supposedly misdiagnosed belonged to
someone who ended up diagnosed with the
disease eight months later wow
the time yeah so like her her scent was
better than their medical technology too
that's so dope wow so since then yeah
that's like a bomb sniffing dog yeah Joy
has since dedicated her nose to science
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
helping doctors at the University of
Manchester and England developed new
methods of diagnosing the aggressive
disease announcing this week that they
have now figured it out with this news
every time now dude
like Scooby Snacks yeah it's cool
because you of course like it would be a
woman because like women's sense of
smell is so much better than men's I
wonder if there's like other women that
can smell all kinds of things yeah is
that like just genetic is that like a
fact that women smell better it is a
fact ask try it on earth like I think
you stepped and dug [ __ ] you could smell
yourself
pregnant their sense of smell gets
heightened because they have to be
careful about [ __ ] they eat and all that
stuff really yeah I I thought it was a
fact that they're better when I got
covered my sense of smell heightened and
did not decrease I could smell like my
neighbor farting three houses when I was
sick I swear to God I would like when I
went yeah like I ordered soup and things
were salty that like should just be like
normal like wonton soup oh yeah that's
crazy because when people had covered
they lost their sense of smelling
reverse whoa for one reason like I was
not able to eat most things because it
was too intense yeah how like things
that were normal to me was too flavorful
yeah too salty too too yeah maybe you're
on to something though maybe you said it
stayed that way no thank God
because I was like I wouldn't be able to
eat anything
and yes you are right uh on basically
almost every test women consistently
score significantly higher than men in
their sense of smell uh and one
researcher has also claimed that the
superior olfactory ability of male of
females is evident even in newborn
babies can you imagine because of this
some [ __ ] creep is like I think I
have the power to taste yeast infections
the Marvel intro
yeah and then all these guys line up
because they're like I might have it in
my dick and he's like oh God
so fast
oh my God I like the voice you chose for
that guy it's basically that female body
inspector I have it in my day
taste it you can have that one by the
way
the one role that I didn't want
the yeasty dick guy just trying to foil
the plants I know can you imagine you
guys are born with a innate superpower
and obviously we're not talking about
laser eye vision but like something like
smelling Parkinson's disease would you
would you submit yourself to science and
for the better betterment of humanity I
mean yeah I mean it seems like it
happened right it doesn't seem fun
though like having to smell bad odors in
your career like poor girl doesn't sound
like a fun one it's not like you're like
smell this she knows it's gonna smell
terrible faster than everyone it makes
me believe that everybody has maybe one
or two of these they just never get in
the situation to figure out what it is
she would have never known like
everyone's got an anomaly of some sort
well because like you know in in quest
aichi we got this dude who has perfect
head spins and then he didn't know until
like National Geographic did like a
special on him that he doesn't have the
ability to like be off balance like you
know your inner earphones
his will automatically adjust you know
like when you're drunk you lose balance
he doesn't yeah he can't have that so
that's the reason why he can tell level
better than like a tool maybe he should
have been a title [ __ ] yeah it's like a
weird thing and he should have been a
construction worker can he do the
Slackline thing like easily I don't know
if he can do that but it's his head it's
what he's on his head like when we were
doing like stage Tech he could tell the
uh the Builder if it was off you know
that's that'll be a good thing like what
if there was a series of tests we can do
when we're kids and then they'll be like
oh you know what you got really good
balance or like really good things you
know because the test that I got when I
was in school is they checked me for
lies they checked my ears and I had to
raise my hand which thing came out and
those tests are like making sure
everybody's normal but like to be normal
yeah we got it we gotta let's do this we
gotta do that we gotta figure out the
other tests to see who's a mutant you
know because his his was crazy because
he has the Guinness World Record for the
amount of spins on your head see if he
knew that earlier he could have been a
really good construction worker yeah
we're walking on a tight on his head
it's something to do with it when he's
on his head I don't know what it is we
probably all got something you guys know
Aaron from barbell
no so there's a uh that company I own um
one of the guys that works with me his
name is Aaron and he's colorblind but he
has [ __ ] like I don't know autistic
Vision or some [ __ ] like that like we'll
get samples samples will come in and
he's like oh this this this uh shade of
like Maroon is off and I'm like how the
[ __ ] do you know and he goes a color
blind guy I still tell from the shade of
gray that it's way off that's crazy is
he called her blind to color deficient
these color blind yeah and he has the
whole level thing too like he'll be like
oh that TV is Hun crooked and then when
we actually measure it it's like a
quarter inch off one on one side or
he'll be like we'll get a t-shirt sample
he's like oh the left sleeve is like
tighter than the right sleeve maybe it's
that things right off the bat he just
tells and I'm like what you know that
thing if you're if you're deficient in
one then the other things get heightened
maybe oh maybe but he could tell all
these crazy things so he was teaching
our old photographer how to color
correct on Adobe and I'm like you don't
even know the colors but then he says he
was like I can tell by what it's
supposed to be and his color correction
was way better than our uh photographer
because I'm like that too I'm like
that's off all this stuff but I'm
usually wrong
I'm like yo that painting's [ __ ]
crooked dog really so would he know if
he was watching I Love Lucy that that's
not in color uh he would because you
know um
what was it called Forum well they don't
watch everything in black and gray right
isn't colorblind like more like sepia
Browns and like in like stones yeah it's
like trendy filter yeah but we bought
them those color blind uh correction
glasses and then he put them on the
first time and we were like we gotta see
what his reaction is he's like he looks
at grass he's like that's what
grasslands
yeah he was just looking at like [ __ ]
like just it was just like what the [ __ ]
fire trucks are red as [ __ ] I'm like
what the [ __ ] oh my God
at least you know he's not racist right
yeah
foreign